while fans still not permitted to attend
raiders home games this season the team
is still trying to figure out ways to
keep the community involved in their
game day experience
eight sports now reporter kevin martin
tells us how a special group of men and
women did so this past sunday
the more than 12 000 construction
workers who contributed to the design
and construction of allegiance stadium
logging more than 6 million hours on a
31 month schedule
were honored in a very special way prior
to this past
sunday's raiders game against kansas
city marking the fourth straight time
this season that the raiders had members
of the community involved in the game
day experience
and in this silver black tradition that
began in 2011
with many writers alumni celebrities and
fans
having the privilege of lighting the
torch since this tradition began
the team and fans have paid tribute to
mr davis by lighting the torch in his
honor
covering the raiders in las vegas i'm
kevin martin
great behind the scenes moment there